today's topic all right seems like the
guys from fresher creed are really upset
we
are better than you [ __ ] period people
want to know our thoughts i'm gonna keep
it really brief all right
i don't have much thoughts on their
platform are they doing some good things
for some people i'm sure i'm no doubt
i'm not even denigrating that we just
came at them for their ideas in regards
to
uh paying for box
and all this stuff thought it was full
of [ __ ] i'm like yo
real last [ __ ]
even more what i find really distasteful
is you come to find out that myron gains
himself right the so-called pickup
artist the master has his own seeking
arrangements account his own profile all
right this is on the web you can find it
this man's out here talking about don't
pay for box don't pay for box he's on a
website for sugar daddies and sugar
babies okay
all right you want to be a giant
hypocrite do your thing okay then you
come to find out this man is talking
about
listen if you we want we want burning
desire from ladies ain't that what they
say
right you want to get their best so you
got to earn it
coming to find out this man is telling
girls in the dms that if they want to
come on the platform they have to
[ __ ] if they don't he gets upset
about it he gets all pissy oh you [ __ ]
all my other boys you won't [ __ ] me then
you can't get on the platform so wait
you want to bang a girl who just wants
to come on the platform for clout and
you think that's burning desire
and again guys i don't even care that he
does the goals about that way to bang
girls do whatever you want you earned
your platform go ahead meets the
hypocrisy of these ideas you preach to
these men that they have to always seek
this thing that this is the way to live
that this is the best way but you don't
even walk to talk that's what i find
distasteful it's like derek jackson
talking about be faithful your wife
don't pay for box come to find out this
man cheating on everyone how are you any
different can you tell me now everyone's
gonna get whoa you know we're attacking
people the madness i don't care about
them atmosphere i don't care about none
of this move with integrity in life
that's it i'm not hearing about it some
scene
oh you can't go on this podcast i don't
care at the end of the day the truth
remains the truth when i came into the
game when i was listening to patrice we
didn't call it red pill we just called
it the truth these [ __ ] is front and
on some points that doesn't mean they're
not helpful to you maybe if you're one
of their fans right maybe they help you
with finances my fitness maybe even they
helped you with game i don't know but
all we talked about were these ideas and
how they were hypocritical here's the
thing you guys been blowing us up man
yeah you guys you guys were blowing this
up with dancing
apparently uh oblivion priest decided to
make a video uh talking smack out of
nowhere out of left field and it's funny
about capping and paying for bucks and i
was like did we talk about this several
months ago like why are you guys
bringing this up like now like what the
hell we're trending man yeah the only
reason we brought it up later is because
we already covered a couple of videos
from that podcast and the second one
after and this we did both podcasts in
the same day the first one and then i
did it came back later on for the second
one i completely forgot about the first
one so i covered the second one and then
months later somebody sent me a link to
it's like hey what did you think about
this conversation so i rewatched it i'm
like hey man there's a lot of dumb
things that were said let me cover it
it's not that deep okay this whole idea
that there's some giant conspiracy is
not that deep
but anyways
if you guys wanted to know that was why
we're trending man yeah we're popping
right now but then i did as always men
like women like numbers don't right and
then i thought to myself why would they
bring this up now uh chris can you show
exhibit a real fast
so let's see here uh they got let's see
these guys have almost a million more
subs than us guys all right so we're the
blue line we're the blue line they're
the red they have 1.38 which is one 1
million three hundred eighty thousand
subscribers guys we only have four
hundred three thousand subscribers okay
we have literally like one less than one
third of their joint right and we got 20
million views and they got 14.9 million
views
very interesting for you guys to go
ahead and make a video insulting us
months after the fact i wonder why oh
it's because we're hotter than you guys
right now i'll just talk about we make
so much money we're getting all these
views these guys are clout chasing
rev when i came on your podcast your
podcast was far smaller i didn't care
that you guys were a smaller podcast i
was like cool you guys seem to do some
interesting content i'll just jump on
i'm not the type of [ __ ] who looks at
people and judges their value or their
uh perception of me based off of how
many followers they have or how many
views they get we cover people who are
far larger than us and who have way
bigger platforms and we cover people
with a hundred subscribers we don't come
at people based off of the size the
following they have we talk about ideas
if you think back about the video when
we said all that stuff about boxing this
it was on the topics we talk about
fresh's past we talk about him faking
press releases we didn't talk about you
paying for box we didn't talk about none
of that [ __ ] you guys are getting so
hyper emotional about this thing it's
funny to me for so called alpha males
you guys don't seem to have any control
over your temper our channel is better
than yours we get more views than you
we've been on less than you we work
harder than y'all [ __ ] we cut our hair
more than you [ __ ] like yo if y'all
get lost we get more ghosts
like if y'all really really wanted three
this [ __ ] preachers married prior to a
[ __ ] beluga whale somewhere and yeah
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] oh they think it's
our 40 years old yo yo oh last nigga's
too bro like yo bruh
i wasn't gonna do this wait the the hand
symbol yo i was not gonna [ __ ] do
this international but y'all got me
hyped now
yo
i know you guys are not talking bro
my man abba looks like he got off a
camel hasn't cut his hair in years
dusty as [ __ ] yo
bruh and this is sudani roasted on you
right now bro
yo i was like yo what enemy you came
from bro now
[ __ ] looking bummy yourself bro am i
you right i'm not gonna [ __ ] because
obviously i'm saying that's a style i
could like we're better than you [ __ ]
we make more money than you [ __ ] we
got a better [ __ ] channel than y'all
[ __ ] we get more views than y'all
[ __ ] the only thing you guys got on us
is now you guys been on longer but i
dare [ __ ] too
next year this time we're going to lap
you [ __ ] because you know what
nobody works harder than us no period we
make more money and that's the worst
part is that i like i like to see i love
to see a black man get paid
get your money i've never that's your
money if your views are stupid your
views are stupid but if you're getting
paid get your money yeah that's not what
i'm here for there's not a single person
that could ever say that we've ever
feigned jealousy or gotten mad about
other people succeeding we move at our
own pace yeah we've been on the platform
along with you congratulations to me
it's not even that deep you guys are
doing well for yourselves good for you
it's crazy i ain't never been mad at a
[ __ ] making money this is about the
idea so all this talk about clout and
all this you guys have lived in miami so
long and you've been faking your
lifestyle for so long that you think
everybody is chasing clout that
everybody wants to be with an instagram
bad your whole platform is based around
clout chasers so that's why your mind is
warped miami's [ __ ] up that's why the
girls you bring on everyone's like yo
who are these dumb broads that you bring
on right because they're all cloud
chasers so you guys mindset is all
warped and [ __ ] it's not like that
everywhere around the world not everyone
is about clout if we were about clout do
you think we'd be covering things like
this pandemic and all these other issues
that [ __ ] derank our youtube channel
it's not about clout at the end of the
day it's always about integrity that's
it for us it's about integrity whether
we win or we lose money y'all dumb ass
[ __ ] with the same tired background
same [ __ ] million plaque we got two
hundred thousand dollar plaques now and
we're gonna get a million ply and we're
gonna get the other channel another two
million as well and fresher's channel
gonna hit a hundred thousand facts we
are better than you [ __ ] period [ __ ]
out of here man and we don't pay for box
these are kind of like
you know what it's like you know it's
like you know i love it that these guys
call themselves alpha and all this other
stuff it makes me laugh because they got
such [ __ ] energy is crazy yeah it's
like when you're talking to a girl about
a topic
you know you're talking you've seen this
before you know you're talking to your
girl about a topic and you guys having a
discussion and she's losing the argument
all of a sudden she starts bringing up
your dick is small what does this have
to do with economics it's like
they do the same thing i find it so
funny that these guys like think they're
alpha and one percent man and all this
other stuff right they lack integrity
they get upset at the most random stuff
when i was on the podcast and they
kicked out that girl one of the girls
besides like yo you're being emotional
no not being emotional i was like bro
like why are you screaming like this no
wonder these girls come on your podcast
and don't respect you you don't command
respect you just yell and get them
kicked out you think that's alpha
behavior
the idea that you can't even get respect
from these ladies
is an indication of the fact that you
don't know what you're doing it's
hyper-emotional you're just screaming
and getting mad
i'm laughing at this because it's
pathetic
i don't know what's wrong but every
episode i see you just screaming get mad
screaming out ladies railroading like
women who aren't prepared with all these
stats and numbers that these ladies are
like oh you want to come on a podcast
like sure uh turns out that eight
percent of all men
well how does that have a way to have a
discussion
just chill [ __ ] it's not that deep i'm
like yo real life [ __ ] don't everybody
yo here's the other thing too these guys
say real ass [ __ ] don't play the box
the ones on seeking arrangements you're
the one
the other one is lying about
having three girls at one time shut the
[ __ ] the other one you know what the
[ __ ] you know you know what kills me
about fresh like if you listen to him
you know he has no king it's it's
painfully obvious yeah that this man
like even when you go watch the the the
the vlogs that he does he's like he has
this whole thing don't lead with money
and like in his bunch of his videos he's
like hey girl i'm gonna shower you with
gifts come on we're gonna go shop for
lambos and ferraris i'm like ruff if it
wasn't for your clout you wouldn't be
out here getting anything let's be real
so i find it so funny as i talk about
paying for bucks you wanna know why this
[ __ ] doesn't wanna pay for a box this
is experience he went to columbia with
his [ __ ] okay
they went to a brothel
he saw a bad woman and he's like oh wow
she's like come upstairs with me he
didn't know it was a whorehouse because
this nigga's so lacking self-awareness
you know he thinks everyone respects him
[ __ ] goober okay he gets in and she's
like twenty dollars he's like you want
me to pay [ __ ] you don't know a
whorehouse when you walk into one where
were you raised do you not
i don't know how you could be a pickup
artist and lack this much self-awareness
so he said
i paid the twenty dollars i banged her
and i felt disgusting afterwards
and that's why i'll never pay for box
ruff
if the first time you eat out is
mcdonald's burger and you say you hate
all restaurants after that's not a
problem with restaurants or that's a
problem with you promise your choices
here's the thing the truth about this
whole escorting and paying for bucks
ceos nba players princes all them they
all pay for bucks they pay for high-end
escorts why discretion
expertise okay i don't care how much
your girl loves you and all that other
stuff if she hasn't studied sex if she
hasn't done all that [ __ ] if she hasn't
taken the time to really learn
she's not as good as other people this
whole idea of like if she have
enthusiasm [ __ ] you ever been with a
girl that's really into you and she's
using her teeth on your blow jobs she
got all the enthusiasm in the world it's
never going to be a substitute for
technique the only [ __ ] were this dumb
ornan who not had a lot of sex or men
who never paid for good bucks even kevin
samuels will come in and say i'll pay
for a box i pay for women to come with
me because he's a real nick patrice
o'neill pays for box the highest [ __ ]
in the game they pay for box not all the
time but sometimes it's convenient so
you want me to tell you that you working
at your middle class job you know more
about what's being alpha and all this
than the ceos the most famous and rich
people in the world okay so yeah their
[ __ ] is beta because they pay for a
box but you right working at the company
as a minimum wage worker for their
company you think you know more about
what it means to be alpha
get him out of here just don't pay for
box say it's not for you it's not for
everyone it's okay but paying 100 for a
hooker and then saying it's not as good
as a random girl i met on the street
probably not
you paid for [ __ ] sometimes you get [ __ ]
service you pay well you get better
service it's not complicated
these guys talk like they're
knowledgeable about this stuff and the
very people they admire pay for box
go have this conversation with kevin
then go go have this conversation with
real [ __ ] go ahead we're the nba
players the same nba player that made
you uh bang three girls in one night
you know that was so stupid about that
this guy man wants me to believe he's at
a pool party okay he was a random he's
at a pool party this nba player comes
with him he's like oh oh my god man do
you know where the coolest parties are
he's like yeah here here can i
can i have your instagram can i have
your instagram oh man we [ __ ] the same
girl oh my god we was in the same [ __ ]
bro i got a story i i got a mansion
party tomorrow why don't you come over
and we're gonna get it later so the guy
hold on so the guy that was looking for
the hottest party happens to have a
mansion party next camp the [ __ ] out of
here with your bogus ass so he needed
your help to find a party in town but he
got a mansion party with 50 girls that
are rolling through and let me ask you
bro let me ask you in this made up
scenario where you're capping the [ __ ]
out of possibilities
you want me to believe that this man had
50 girls and none of them were paid
hmm you think that these girls that you
banged there supposedly that you had all
three but you didn't want to threesome
because you wanted to go one at a time
because you were too awkward enough
you want me to believe that these girls
had burning desire for you of course not
they wanted to [ __ ] the nba player at
best they didn't want to get around with
you
but you think none of these girls are
paid they pay for box all these guys
these high value man they all pay for
bucks
so
man listen you guys trust what you ever
want to trust follow whoever want to
follow i don't think i need to play the
rest of the video
[Music]
my
[Music]
i